[Musik]
parteitag mit zündstoff steht die cdu
chefin in leipzig vor einem machtkampf
mit ihrem rivalen märz anklage gegen
israels regierungschef wegen
korruptionsvorwürfen muss sich benjamin
netanjahu vor gericht verantworten
hoch und umstritten nach acht jahren
bauzeit rollen die ersten autos über die
gigantische hochmoselbrücke
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers das sind ein paar von
unseren themen guten abend hinein heute
um 7 wir haben für sie diesen
nachrichten donnerstag zusammengefasst
mit dem sport natürlich auch und mit
norbert lehmann junior von mir
es gibt einiges an unruhe aber auch
spannung in der cdu vor dem
bundesparteitag morgen in leipzig da
geht es um themen aber auch um posten
partei chefin annegret kramp karrenbauer
hat heute noch mal vor personaldebatten
gewarnt für sie wird der parteitag zur
bewährungsprobe
mit diesen strittigen themen gucken sie
uns an die k frage kommt es zum showdown
zwischen ihr und friedrich merz wird
künftig per urwahl über die
kanzlerkandidatur entschieden
auch die forderung nach einer
frauenquote birgt politischen
sprengstoff die frauen union will die
besetzung von listen nach dem
reißverschlussprinzip und das thema
huawei eine beteiligung der chinesen
beim aufbau des 5g mobilfunknetzes ist
in der union ebenfalls heftig umstritten
details von mathis feldhoff
höchstpersönlich schaut die vorsitzende
der cdu noch mal ob das c für christlich
noch an seinem platz stieg am morgen in
berlin hatte greenpeace das c aus der
parteizentrale gestohlen in der
klimapolitik achte die parteien nicht
auf die schöpfung aber das c deshalb
nicht verdient
die christdemokraten versuchen es mit
humor zu nehmen so ein c für christlich
kite und nachhaltigkeit kann auch
greenpeace nicht schaden leiden wir also
gerne für kurze zeit einmal aus
offiziell soll es ein arbeitsparteitag
werden aber die frage wer die cdu als
nächster kanzler kandidat oder
kandidatin für kramp karrenbauer oder
etwa friedrich merz ist in der cdu nicht
geklärt auch auf diesem parteitag wird
die frage nicht entschieden
diese partei kann jeden klugen kopf
candide auch kritisch konstruktive
stimme gut gebrauchen friedrich merz ist
eine davon insofern wird das morgen
schon entspannende aussprache werden
doch der showdown den mancher noch vor
wochen befürchtet hat er fällt wohl aus
die volkspartei braucht diese debatten
und so gesehen ist alles spannend was
wir diskutieren
hoffentlich wird das alles sachlich und
zu sagen wenn der gegenseitige respekt
und achtung
spannend auch das thema huawei die
forderung die chinesen beim ausbau des
5g netzes auszuschließen wäre ein
affront gegenüber der eigenen kanzlei
china ist ein wichtiger
wirtschaftsfaktor
wir sind für freien handel aber es ist
auch ein autoritäres regime
und dann hast du noch die frauenquote
auch sie spaltet die cdu und soll
deshalb auf nächstes jahr vertagt
der life nach leipzig zu matthias
fornoff matthias guten abend wird denn
die parteitagsregie na wenn wir suchen
die personalfrage jetzt möglichst klein
zu halten oder schiebt die sich
unweigerlich in den vordergrund am ende
naja angelegt ist das hier als
programmparteitag die cdu will
deutlicher zeigen wofür sie steht nach
14 jahren ununterbrochenen regieren mit
koalitionen und kompromissen ist eine
klarere positionierung das ziel das hat
wahlschlappen gegeben herbe verluste in
serie
bundesweit steckt die cdu und
umfragetief man spürt hier das viel
druck im kessel ist und die parteichefin
annegret kramp karrenbauer ist vor einem
jahr für zwei jahre gewählt worden
das aber ist die einzige klarheit
ansonsten ist die personelle aufstellung
der cdu nach der ära merkel unklar
wenn man hier mit den delegierten
spricht dann fällt ganz oft das wort von
der geschlossenheit über die frage wer
kanzlerkandidat oder kanzlerkandidat in
der union wird wird weniger gesprochen
dass wird klein gehalten mir kommt so
ein bisschen vor wie
berühmte elefant im raum jeder sieht ihn
und jeder versucht ihn zu ignorieren so
gut es geht
ein gespräch mit der cdu parteichefin
nachher im heute-journal matthias für
den moment herzlichen dank wir hören und
sehen uns morgen wieder jetzt nach
israel wo es für regierungschef benjamin
netanyahu ernst wird denn er soll wegen
korruptionsvorwürfen vor gericht
generalstaatsanwalt david heyman selbe
lied erklärte niemand stehe über dem
gesetz auch der ministerpräsident nicht
ich lag die namen wegen betrugs untreue
und bestechlichkeit
netanyahu weist alle vorwürfe zurück und
spricht von einer politischen hexenjagd
nikolaus albrecht beobachtet das für uns
in tel aviv nicola was heißt das jetzt
für die politische zukunft von benjamin
netanjahu ist ja immerhin der längste
amtierende ministerpräsident seit
israels staatsgründung nun in kenia hat
immer gesagt dass er auch im falle einer
anklage nicht freiwillig zurücktreten
wird und das muss er nach israelischem
gesetz auch nicht und auch in der
bevölkerung hat er trotz allem noch viel
unterstützung gerade jetzt in diesen
minuten sind die anhänger seine anhänger
auf der straße um ihre solidarität zu
bekunden
politisch wird es trotzdem für ihn eng
denn er hat in diesem jahr nach zwei
parlaments waren es nicht geschafft eine
regierung zu bilden und das land steuert
gerade auf eine dritte wahl zu und
internet hat politische gegner in der
eigenen partei und die könnten natürlich
jetzt die juristische entscheidung dazu
nutzen eine palastrevolte zu starten und
als politisches ende tatsächlich
einläuten
nico lambrechts zdf tel aviv vielen dank
für diese hintergrundinformationen heute
abend immer mehr türken beantragen asyl
in deutschland allein im oktober waren
es über 1000 menschen sie fürchten
politische verfolgung daheim
für viele ist jetzt eine weitere sorge
dazu gekommen denn in der türkei ist ein
anwalt wegen angeblicher spionage für
deutschland festgenommen worden
und er hatte wohl viele akten über
asylbewerber dabei weil er im auftrag
der deutschen botschaft
und des bundesamts für migration in der
türkei angaben von flüchtlingen
überprüft hatte jörg brase berichtet
dass es war am 17
september auf dem weg in die deutsche
botschaft in ankara als man ihn festnahm
bei sich hatte er unterlagen über
deutsche asylverfahren türkischer
staatsangehöriger in deutschland im
auftrag deutscher behörden sollte er
deren angaben überprüfen unter anderem
mit hilfe einer für anwälte zugänglichen
datenbank über strafverfahren in der
türkei wo doch deshalb beschuldigt ihn
die türkische staatsanwaltschaft der
spionage für das auswärtige amt in
berlin ein höchst sensibler fall von
dort gab es heute nur eine schriftliche
stellungnahme
wir setzen uns intensiv für eine klärung
der vorwürfe und eine aufhebung der
untersuchungshaft ein der kooperations
anwalt hat für unsere botschaft die
international übliche und aus unserer
sicht unstrittig zulässige unterstützung
geleistet das ist auch europaweit eine
gängige praxis die inhaftierung ist für
uns daher nicht nachvollziehbar
nun befinden sich sensible daten
türkische asylbewerber in den händen der
türkischen justiz
das setzt sowohl die asylbewerber als
auch türkische anwälte unter druck der
anwalt und oppositionsabgeordnete sint
henricus kann keinen verstoß seines
kollegen erkennen wenn eine akte nicht
als vertraulich eingestuft ist kann ein
anwalt der die zulassung hat die
dokumente einsehen und mit seinen
mandanten teilen der die gerichtsakten
stehen allen offen
aussenminister maß traf heute in japan
ein wollte die festnahme des anwalts
aber nicht kommentieren
anscheinend will man den fall nicht zu
hoch hängen denn er hat durchaus
politische sprengkraft ein großes
zukunftsthema jetzt für deutschland es
geht um unsere innenstädte und um die
frage wie wir uns künftig darin bewegen
sollen wenn möglich zu fuß per rad oder
bus sagen bund länder und kommunen und
haben heute ein bündnis für moderne
mobilität gegründet für autofahrer wird
es wohl schwieriger vor allem beim
parken und für anwohner möglicherweise
auch teurer christian hübscher berichtet
ein anwohnerparkausweis garantiert noch
keinen parkplatz das weiß jeder genervt
der großstadt autofahrer
aber er sorgt zumindest manchmal für
einen kleinen heimvorteil und das für
relativ wenig geld
bisher kostet anwohnerparken zwischen 10
und 30 euro pro jahr gedeckelt vom bund
künftig sollen die städte frei sein in
der preisgestaltung so plant des bundes
verkehrsminister scheuer
die kommunen sind auf uns zugekommen und
haben gesagt warum gibt es eigentlich
den deckel wir können das doch selber
besser organisieren es soll keiner auch
denken dass die parkraumbewirtschaftung
automatisch teurer wird wir müssen aber
das grundvertrauen in kommunale
verantwortung haben
die politik spielt zum beispiel nach
kopenhagen hier kostet das
anwohnerparken 158 euro im jahr mehr als
fünfmal so viel wie in deutschland
es ist die hoffnung auf die grundlegende
verkehrswende mehr menschen in bus und
bahn wurde aufs fahrrad zu bringen
länder und kommunen warten auf genau
solche anreize wie preise die heute da
sind sind extrem niedrig auch im
vergleich zu anderen man muss eben da
wieder mehr markt kriterien
berücksichtigen dass müssen die kommunen
am ende selber entscheiden wir fragen
nach im feierabendverkehr von kiel ist
es gerecht mehr geld für anwohnerparken
zu verlangen um städte grüner zu machen
die haben wir schon die mieten hier in
kiel alles was im umkreis es ist ja
günstiger und wenn man dann auch noch
mehr für den parkraum zahlen muss ist
natürlich doppelt gemeinde vielleicht
nicht unbedingt gerecht aber die meisten
heute auch mehr als so ein auto ganz
viele haben dass jährlich zwei oder drei
autos sind das ist einfach zu viel
anwohnerparken wird künftig wohl teurer
werden wie teuer genau da wollte sich
heute noch niemand festlegen wie umgehen
mit den flüchtlingen die auf den
griechischen inseln stranden die
griechische regierung beantwortet diese
frage jetzt mit einer schärferen
flüchtlingspolitik
sie will die völlig überfüllten lager
auf lesbos und sahm ausschließen mehr
als 17.000 flüchtlinge halten sich
allein auf lesbos auf rund 90.000
einwohnern auf der insel die alten
einrichtungen sollen durch ein
geschlossenes lager auf lesbos ersetzt
werden mit platz für bis zu 5000
menschen die dann dort festgehalten
würden annette hilsenbeck
das lager maria wächst unaufhaltsam die
zahl der menschen kaum zu bewältigen und
täglich kommen neue zu denen die warten
wie über ihren asylantrag entschieden
wird mohammed haus seit zwei wochen hier
und klagt über die zustände das essen
die enger wir haben hier keinen strom
wir haben hier nichts wir leben wie im
käfig wie höhlenmenschen die stimmung
oft exklusiv die zustände dramatisch die
griechische regierung hat jetzt reagiert
sie will die lage auf den inseln
schließen und stattdessen geschlossene
lager neu errichten
für die bewohner von lesbos eine
entlastung so lange so viele kommen wie
jetzt kann diese maßnahme zwar das
problem nicht lösen aber sie kann den
traum von europa zerstören von einem
flüchtlingslager moria auf lesbos für
die bevölkerung hier ist es jedenfalls
positiv schutzbedürftige wie familien
etwa sollen künftig aufs festland
gebracht werden ein bruch mit der
bisherigen politik nach der alle
asylbewerber in den sogenannten hot
spots auf ihre asyl entscheidung warten
müssen
die anderen müssen bis zur entscheidung
in den geschlossenen kämpft bleiben
menschenrechtler melden kritik an die
zeitliche periode in der asylbewerber
die wenig chancen haben festgehalten
werden dürfen kann jetzt 18 monate
betragen das entspricht nicht den
menschenrechten noch können sich die
migranten frei bewegen im lager von
moria doch das erste geschlossene lage
auf den inseln soll bereits im nächsten
frühling fertig sein
griechenland verschärft seine
migrationspolitik unser nächstes thema
beschäftigt großbritannien und bei
weitem nicht nur großbritannien und es
geht auch nicht einfach nur ums
königshaus die frage ist ob der
zweitälteste sohn der queen prinz andrew
von den machenschaften seines inzwischen
toten freundes jeffrey epstein wusste
und sogar selbst mitgemacht hat apps
team ein multimillionär soll
minderjährige zum sex gezwungen haben
und andrew war regelmäßig bei ihm in den
usa zu gast
der prinz sagt jetzt er wolle die
ermittlungen unterstützen und sich aber
erstmal aus der öffentlichkeit
zurückziehen aus london andreas stamm
ein leben in der
öffentlichkeit schicksal eines
britischen prinzen für andrew vorbei er
fährt in den vorruhestand der zweite
sohn der queen zieht sich von allen
royalen verpflichtungen zurück ein novum
andrew werde so die erklärung wenn nötig
auch mit den us strafverfolgungsbehörden
im missbrauchsskandal apps die ihnen
zusammenarbeiten
die königliche familie hatte keine wahl
musste ihn zum rückzug zwingen das
interview hat seine glaubwürdigkeit
immer weiter zerstört zum schutz der
monarchie musste gehandelt werden
das interview am wochenende gedacht als
befreiungsschlag gerät zum desaster
andrew zeigt kein mitgefühl für die
opfer des us geschäftsmann saps die nein
man den andrew als freund bezeichnete
bei ihm übernachtete auch nach dessen
verurteilung als sexualstraftäter im
interview keine distanzierung reue ich
dass er sich offensichtlich unziemlich
verhalten hat und ziemlich er war ein
sexualverbrecher ja ja ich wollte
höflich sein
der prinz weist auch vorwürfe zurück er
habe sex mit der damals minderjährigen
virginia robert gehabt einem opfer apps
dienst doch er wirkt unglaubwürdig
solch negative schlagzeilen hat es noch
nie gegeben nicht mal bei der abdankung
edward des 8 1936 damals für einen tag
aber nicht vergleichbar mit dem was wir
die vergangenen tage gesehen haben und
da wird wohl einiges folgen
denn nun dürften ermittlungen zu andrews
rolle im missbrauchsfall apps team an
fahrt aufnehmen
es drohen weitere enthüllungen der
rückzug aus der öffentlichkeit nur akute
schadensbegrenzung
seit heute mittag rollen die autos über
einen neuen koloss aus stahl und beton
die hochmoselbrücke in rheinland-pfalz
spektakulär aber auch umstritten die
brücke ist teil der neuen b 50 einer
schnelleren verbindung zwischen dem
rhein main gebiet und den beneluxstaaten
20 minuten fahrzeit soll die neue
strecke einsparen unübersehbar thront
die hochmoselbrücke zwischen hunsrück
und eifel 1,7 kilometer geht es
schnurgerade über die mosel
bis zu 165 meter hoch damit ist sie die
zweithöchste brücke in deutschland es
würde sogar der kölner dom darunter
passen christopher heinzl nach acht
jahren bauzeit dürfen endlich alle über
die neue hochmoselbrücke fahren ein
gigant spannt sich über das flusstal in
rheinland pfalz zwischen dem hunsrück
und der eifel zwischen zeltingen rachtig
und ürzig die meinung vor ort gespalten
es schon irgendwo wird für uns insgesamt
denke ich mal etwas sinnvolles werden
oder sein weil wir halt einfach
erreichbarer sind auch nur das war schon
vermischte die landschaft ist
fortschritt und mein hobby hatte das
landschafts will passt jetzt natürlich
strittig ich finde die optisch einmal
sehr schön
ja und für die lkw ist eine
erleichterung denn die müssen nun nicht
mehr die mosel hänge rauf und runter
fahren
lange zeit war es europas größte
brückenbaustelle 1,7 kilometer lang bis
zu 165 meter hoch aufwändig wurden über
insgesamt zehn pfeiler zug um zug
zusammengeschweißte stahlteile über den
fluss geschoben
tausende tonnen schwer zur
stabilisierung kam unterirdische
betonsäulen in den steilhang ein
überwachungssystem liefert ständig daten
riesige stahl dübel verankern die
pfeiler kosten rund 175 millionen euro
über die mosel führt nun die
zweithöchste brücke deutschlands und die
überleitung führt direkt zum sport ja
und da schauen wir als erstes auf die
idee davis cup endrunde in madrid da
haben die deutschen tennis herren das
viertelfinale erreicht und das sogar als
gruppen-erster im letzten spiel gegen
chile gab es heute einen 2 1 sieg
erstes ziel erreicht die gruppenphase
überstanden entsprechend groß die
zufriedenheit in den deutschen
gesichtern dank philipp kohlschreiber
die deutsche nummer zwei zeigte im
ersten einzel gegen nicolas raemy eine
starke leistung ein druckvolles spiel
von der grundlinie und holt sich den
ersten satz mit 6 zu 4
auch im zweiten durchgang ließ
kohlschreiber bei eigenem aufschlag
keinen einzigen breakball zu und beendet
nach 68 minuten die partie mit dem
ersten matchball zum 6 3
das zweite einzel wie auch das doppel
unbedeutend für den einzug ins
viertelfinale
das für die deutschen herren morgen
abend auf dem programm steht unter geht
es dann gegen großbritannien nach der
länderspielpause geht die bundesliga
weiter auf starke union berlin trifft am
samstag auf tabellenführer gladbach
herbstmeister oder gar deutsche
meisterschaft das überraschungsteam von
marco rose muss sich solchen fragen
stellen
es ist nicht so dass sie in
mönchengladbach die spielfreien
bundesliga wochen in saus und braus
verbracht haben und doch mal guckt sich
halt ein bisschen er lieber die tabelle
an guckt gerne auf die tabelle ist fast
jeden tag auf die tabelle und den klausi
geil aus und freut mich sieben siegen in
den vergangenen acht bundesliga spielen
vier punkte vorsprung die fohlen
galoppieren durch die liga wie einst in
den 70er jahren fünfmal deutscher
meister das letzte mal 1977 mit stürmer
jupp heynckes und trainer udo lattek
mann soll träumen die fans sollen zahlen
ausschneiden ich finde das cool das
einzige problem an der ganzen sache ist
ja dass wir jetzt noch 23 spiele zu
spielen haben sonst ist kein problem da
aber das problem ist halt sehr groß das
nächste mögliche problem wartet in
berlin aber egal wie das spiel ausgehen
wird erster bleibt die borussia für
mindestens eine weitere woche
das war schon von mir danke dir ganz
ruhig aber mild das ist das wetter in
kurzform die langform hat gleich katja
oliver und der kollege claus kleber hat
das heute journal um 21.45 uns gibt's
morgen wieder punkt 7 wir freuen uns
wenn sie dabei sind aber erst mal in
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren jetzt
geht ein trüber donnerstag zu ende mit
etwas fiesem nieselregen dass sie ihn
sie an der blauen farbe
es gab allerdings auch sonnige lücken
zum beispiel am niederrhein im taunus
oder auch im südwesten deutschlands
der regen von heute zieht in der nacht
weiter richtung ostseeküste und nordsee
aber viel gefährlicher ist der regen der
hier von frankreich heran kommt denn der
fällt zum beispiel in der eifel und im
hunsrück auf gefrorenem boden über das
spiegelglatt denn etwa südlich der
nördlichen mittelgebirge sinken die
temperaturen auf +2 bis -3 grad im
nordosten unter den regenwolken bleibt
es milder und milder für uns alle wird
es dann morgen über tag meist erwarten
und sieben bis zwölf grad und nur selten
bleibt es kühler
dass dann dort wo sich nebel und
hochnebel nicht so bald auflöst in
norddeutschland sollte das aber dank des
süd will es häufig klappen im emsland
und auch wieder rein kann es allerdings
fallen am vormittag noch leicht tropfen
in der mitte ist es häufig trüb ob nun
in kassel oder in erfurt auch an der
donau halten sich nebelfelder länger im
süden dagegen es ist zum teil sonnig
besonders auf den bergen und mit diesem
ruhigen spätherbst wetter geht es weiter
mit bis zu 15 grad mitführen
unterstützung am samstag am albrand
schönen abend noch